the election result and you can actually
understand that through reading more
fiction I truly believe that so I think
the one thing I will do is figure out a
way to read a little bit more and take a
step back I would like to write another
book in the future but I'm gonna spend
some time letting that percolate and
maybe not do it in an election year
again no that's that's a lot on your
plate that's for sure good clothes for
we're gonna open up the floor to some
questions but before we do that I just
wanted to ask you something else
because we have seen a lot of protests
going on many here in South Florida as
well and after this historic election
there's still a lot of divisive nough
sout there you're still hopeful about
what's to come yes I think that this
will burn out that the election result
while it might have been shocking to
people who are unhappy about it
with time I think that that eases a
little bit I respect their right to
protest I hope they would do so
peacefully of course and I also think
that they hopefully can just take a
breath and wait and see what happens but
of course there is a way to participate
in our democracy and if you're unhappy
with the result there is a way to get
involved that's how our founding fathers
set it up so yes I remain optimistic
about America in all sorts of ways and
especially they had just having been
traveling this past week in all these
different states Americans are very kind
you know I saw that yesterday with
people standing in line waiting for me
and at the villages in Lakeland and in
Tampa and last night in Fort Myers and
people being so kind maybe bringing me
something that they made for me or just
actually even stopping by to say I want
to thank you for working so hard to
bring us your opinion on the news and
for they call me the voice of reason or
the mother on the five so people are
very kind and we have a lot more in
common than we might think and truly
this might not happen out of protest but
if you feel like there's been somebody
that you've had to unfriend on Facebook
or that you might not be able to connect
with a neighbor anymore on because of
politics I mean it was quite vitriolic
friendships are broken up I actually met
a makeup
artists along the way who told me that
she and her husband were not speaking
because of the election he was planning
to vote for Trump she wanted to vote for
Clinton and I asked her I said do you
have a dog and she said no I said well
you might want to get one because it's
something that can bring people back
together absolutely this is so
interesting but I know you have
questions yell or and so we're going to
stop if this is a good time for you and
let's take questions and guys we have
about 14 minutes for questions I can get
a lot answered in 30 so you can line up
at the mic you will forgive me if I say
sometime down the line sorry we have to
cut it off but let's get started yes sir
so I'm going to out myself first of all
thank you very much for a lovely
discussion there are now officially
three Republicans and three aficionados
of the Denver Post and Rocky Mountain
News in the room and I'm not going to
tell you who the third one is because
she may not want me to I I am an
infectious disease doctor and one of
george w bush's great legacies was what
he did to combat AIDS in Africa and I
frequently find myself defending
President Bush in those terms what do
you think his legacy is going to be
years down the road is he going to come
out positively or negatively in in
history well thank you and everyone this
is an author also who is presenting here
he is an infectious disease doctor who
has just written a book about miracles
in medicine so um thank you for that
he's also from Denver um one of the
things that George W Bush would tell us
in that last year was that he wasn't
worried about his legacy you know I
would tell the reporters that and
reporters would say oh that's baloney of
course he is but he would say to me well
last year I read three books about
George Washington and if historians are
still analyzing the first president then
the forty-third doesn't have a lot to
worry about because he'll never know and
he moved on with his life you know he's
done an amazing job I think as a post
president as well one has been very
respectful of his successor being very
silent but he's gone on to create so
an amazing Institute at the bush library
the the PEPFAR program the President's
Emergency Plan for AIDS relief is even
something that Democrats will say that
was amazing it was very bold back in
2003 to go forward with that it is
credited with saving a generation in
Africa and that wasn't just because he
felt a humanitarian obligation there was
also a national security component to
that because one of the things that
condi rice and : Powell came to him to
say was that we are about to have failed
States all across Africa because these
young people are dying or their parents
are dying the young people are dying and
the ones that are remain the only people
to take care of them
are bad actors and we have the means to
do something different and so he has
continued to work on that in Africa and
in fact I think he's planning to visit
later this year
he actually instilled in me a passion
for Africa in fact I've been several
times since I volunteered at Living Hope
which is a faith-based Center in Africa
that gets PEPFAR money but I also have
become aligned with Mercy Ships and that
is a charitable hospital ship work that
works off the coast of West Africa and
it's all surgery and the work that they
do is amazing and angelic really I think
also for President Bush that you're
going to see him continue to do some
amazing things and maybe next year Miami
Book Fair would like to have him back to
talk about a new book he has coming out
in March President Bush has just
finished or is finishing up the
portraits of 98 wounded warriors who
served under his command he started
painting after the White House and this
is something he learned from Winston
Churchill after he retired he went to
Churchill wrote an essay about how
people in retirement need to have like
three hobbies and you have to actually
take lessons painting is something that
Winston Churchill did and 43 thought
I'll give it a shot turns out he's
actually very very good and so he
continues to serve in lots of different
ways and so his legacy while unknown to
all of us because we won't live long
enough to see it I do think it he is
assured as being a very good man and a
wonderful president what is your
relation
ship with him today we're very friendly
he's great
and I actually do some work with the
Barbara Bush Literacy Foundation a
amazing group they are helping people
become literate all across America it's
amazing the bay like a 98% success rate
for the work that they do and I recently
saw him at one of those events and we're
buddies mr. Perino prior to the invasion
of Iraq for for many months I remember
George Bush on television talking about
we don't want the smoking gun to be in
the form of a mushroom cloud and weapons
of mass destruction that turned out to
be false information do you think that
information is the product of an
intelligence community that doesn't know
what it's doing or do you think the
dissemination of false information prior
to the invasion the unprovoked invasion
of a foreign country was was part of a
some conspiracy to you know invade Iraq
and were you aware of it at the time if
you weren't can you share with us what
it's like to be with a group of people
who are disseminating false information
either sincerely or not got it thank you
this has been a debate that's been
ongoing I would say that the information
was not false the information was wrong
and if you look at intelligence agencies
all across the world had the same
information and that is what it was and
the decision was made after UN Security
Council I was actually not there at the
time I was at the White House Council on
Environmental Quality so it would not
have had access to that information
anyway in a follow-up question after the
war had started everyone seems to agree
that the occupation of Iraq was not
handled efficiently you were around
President Bush during the occupation
after the war did you feel like
President Bush was focused on on the
administration of post-invasion Iraq you
know and thank you I would encourage you
to read his book decision points there's
an entire two chapters that deal with
this and explain his decision make
along the way and I was also there and I
was a spokesperson for him when we did
the surge which was to turn it around
and which he did just one quick question
but a note in front of that Kevin
Sullivan is a good friend of mine and he
totally yeah he told me you were one of
the nicest and smartest people he had
the pleasure of working on about him
thanks for coming out question is a
Republican presidential spokesperson
what do you think of the relationship
that Donald Trump has with the media and
what advice would you give him well he
didn't take any of my advice it's a the
relationship between a president and the
press corps is always adversarial it's
set up that way that doesn't mean that
isn't also mutually beneficial
beneficial right because Donald Trump
certainly benefited from a lot of media
attention there's one thing he knows how
to do very very well is to get the media
to cover his stories and then also he
even gets them to cover this when he is
saying that they're biased they cover
that it's like he can't lose there's
also a lot of different tactics now in
terms of how you can communicate with
people so Twitter is a way that Donald
Trump has been able to communicate
directly with people every time he sends
a tweet guess what happens the media
covers it so I think that it will be
interesting to see how the media try to
try to get its footing and decide how
they're going to cover I would urge the
Trump White House as I did the Obama
White House allow that access from the
reporters to the the government it is
one of the things our founding fathers
set up they were they were right to do
so and the media is critical for us to
keep our democracy going Plus who's to
say that the story is gonna be bad one
of the things I was saying to jackie
earlier is I remember back when
President Obama first took office one of
the things he first did was to keep the
White House photographers the ones the
work for the wire services ap AFP
Reuters he wouldn't let him into some of
the
things that we used to let them in for
and I said he never takes a bad picture
so why not just let them in you know
it's a way to make sure that that keeps
that that relationship keeps going
places that don't have a free media turn
out like Venezuela or Russia or places
that you wouldn't necessarily want to
live so the media might frustrate them
as it does the other side as well but
it's a necessary and not even an evil
it's just a necessary thing in our
society I think we probably have time
for one more question maybe two so let's
mendiola I love you I love you under
five thank you for the great job but you
did for George W Bush who was one of our
best presidents and your love for our
country I have been asked to serve on
the Barbara Bush Literacy Foundation and
I'm gonna be getting a call from you
yesterday tomorrow with Debbie and I was
wondering and I was wondering if you
would like to tell this great group of
people what exactly what do you see
foundation do on how we can help improve
the literacy of so many unprivileged
kids because I don't know myself what we
do and I think that this would be a
great group to get involved with thank
you I'll answer quickly so Barbara Bush
after she left the White House continued
to work in the on the issue that she
cared about the most which was literacy
it was actually quite surprising to me
because in my circle of friends and in
my family like everybody knows how to
read okay that's not even a question
they learned to read sometimes now when
they're three or four years old the
thing that's frustrating and a little
sad is that I think I might be wrong on
the number but let's just say it's 30
million Americans either are illiterate
or I think it's called under literate
there's a description for it but can't
read well and can't function well in
society that number has been the same
for several decades partly that is due
to immigration flows and things like
that but what's amazing
is that one of the things that Barbara
Bush Foundation has done is they've
teamed up with high school students and
you know high school students sometimes
have to do volunteer work to get credits
before they graduate so one of the
programs that they have in several
states and I believe Florida is one of
them is they match up a high school
student with like a third grader let's
say a third grade and they have
benchmarks they have to meet okay
there's a curriculum that they have to
follow and they will not be able to get
their credit if they don't actually
succeed with this child and that's why I
say they've had a 98% success rate in
helping not just the children but also
the adults sir when you join the board
which I hope you will do you will see
something that will amaze you because
it's not just that they work for with
children's literacy because a lot of
people are doing that it's adult
literacy it's so important in every time
they have an event which is about three
or four times a year they invite
somebody whose life has been changed
because now they can read and now they
have books in the home and they're
reading to their children and how it
changes their life and these people who
have never been able to read before get
up in front of a crowd of 500 people and
they give a speech and it will just give
you chills it's one of the most amazing
wonderful things I've ever been involved
in so I'm happy to be a part of that and
I'll guess I'll talk to on the phone
tomorrow at 3:00 we're doing a
conference call I'm so sorry but we've
come to the end of our time for
questions we have to stay on schedule
not only for your interest but also for
c-span who is recording this I want to
thank our author dana perino jackie nest
raw for her interview thank you
and before you go before you go I'd like
to remind you that books are being sold
right outside here and I can't think of
about a holiday book than one with dog
pictures for all of your veggies and the
books are being signed this Purina will
be signing them past the elevators and
around the corner and she will need to
nip off there very quickly so she's
there to sign your books for you
so we appreciate all of you coming and
we look forward to seeing you at another
session thank you very much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and you're watching book TV on c-span -
this is live coverage of the 33rd annual
Miami Book Fair of course that was Dana
Perino and she'll be with us a little
bit later to do a call-in program as
well and now we are joined by Sid
Ziggler whose book is called fair play
how LGBT athletes are reclaiming their
rightful place in sports here's the
cover mr. Ziegler first of all you're
the co-founder of out sports calm which
is what out Sports was started many
years ago because you know being gay
sports fans we realized that gay people
didn't want to talk about sports and
people in sports didn't want to talk
about gay issues but we did and and we
knew that there was a large group of
people who were like us and so we
started allosaurus to start talking
about these issues talk about homophobia
in sports athletes coming out on their
teams and and slowly we kind of became
the experts in the area because we were
the only ones talking about it I'm
talking about back in 1999 in 2000 and
2001 and slowly as professional athletes
started coming out of the closet in
women's sports and in men's sports the
mainstream media started paying a little
more attention because they like it they
like to pay its head to the professional
athletes you know the high school
athletes that we focus on and the and
the smaller school college athletes that
we write a lot about the mainstream
media just doesn't talk much about them
but you know their their stories are
integral to the story that we try to
tell about where LGBT people are in
sports in your book fair play you talk
about the big five what are those the
big five is the big five men's
professional sports leagues and a lot of
people say it's the big four that would
be the and I would say it's a big one
the NFL right the NFL is king in America
it's the most even with the declining
ratings as you're still the most
powerful cultural institution that we
have at the NBA a Major League Baseball
and the National Hockey League the Big
Five would
be adding Major League Soccer and and I
like to add major league soccer I like
to call it the big five because the only
openly gay athlete we have in any of
those leagues is Robbie Rogers who plays
for the LA Galaxy and who won an MLS Cup
with them he is currently the only
openly gay athlete in the big five yeah
and I say you know publicly out
certainly there are athletes who are out
to some teammates they have boyfriend
they're out to their families but we the
public don't know or we don't talk about
it and yeah right now the only one is
Robbie Rogers and and and there's only
been one other in history and that was
Jason Collins Michael Sam with the NFL
never made a regular-season roster so
there's only been two openly gay men in
those five leagues ever and there's only
one right now
do you advocate for gay athletes to come
out while they're actively playing you
know if this is a this is a tough
question for our movement because of
course coming out is a very personal
journey for anybody and and it's it
begins the personal journey journey it
ends as a personal journey and so you
know I want people to come out one
because it helps change the conversation
in America men's sports are held up as
these bastions of masculinity and to
have a game man to come out in that
world really helps and it has helped
change the conversation about what it is
to be a gay man what it is to be
masculine but the other the bigger
reason that I advocate for people coming
out in sports is because of what it does
for them personally every single athlete
that we've written about with a tiny
fraction of of maybe literally a couple
of a few hundred um exceptions have the
same exact story they're scared to death
that come out of the closet to their
teammates
once they do it they are shocked by the
support they receive from their
teammates and their coaches the men who
are the most homophobic in their
comments in the locker room are some of
the first guys to hug them and embrace
them and tell them I love you and the
only regret these athletes have is that
they didn't do it sooner and it's not
like oh this is the experience of some
of the athletes this is the experience
of 99% of the athletes that we've
written about in high school college
pros Olympic level in Tennessee and
Kentucky in California in Europe in
Australia so the biggest reason that I
advocate for people coming out at sports
because it will make your life better
and your your eyes will open up to just
how much people love you from your book
Fair Play for years people have asked me
about when we would see the gay Jackie
Robinson there are two ways to look at
that one we already have and two we
never will so I kind of balk at this
term gay Jackie Robinson and a lot of
people use it to talk about the first
big sports are men's sports Starks we've
had some women's sports stars like
Sheryl Swoopes first big men's sports
star to come out of the amount of the
closet and be that Jackie Robinson type
person that helps change the
conversation but to understand who
Jackie Robinson was and what he was you
have to understand where civil rights
were in 1947 when he first played a
major league baseball black people I had
trouble voting in a lot of states they
couldn't sit in the they couldn't sit in
certain parts of a restaurant or even
enter some restaurant they couldn't
drink from water fountains where gay
people are today is nowhere near that
our our rights have far advanced beyond
where we are in the sports world so we
couldn't have a gay Jackie Robinson
because we're just not today where the
rights of African Americans were in 1947
but the other flip side is you know I
look at instead of one seminal figure
all of the young athletes who have come
out since Dave co-pay did in in in the
mid-70s Dave was an NFL player he was
the first former professional athlete to
come out of the closet men or women and
since then just the trickle and now a
flood of all the younger kids who are
really changing sports from the ground
up so it's just a different way of
looking at it but we're never gonna have
a single seminal gay Jackie Robinson
even if an NFL MVP came out tomorrow
he's still not what Jackie Robinson was
in 1947 what's the significance of
Michael Sam there are so many different
ways to look at the Michael Sam story
you know again Michael was embraced by
his teammates the athletes at the
University of Missouri and they knew
before he came out correct but before he
came out publicly he played his entire
senior season with Missouri
I was the SEC Defensive Player of the
Year wearing when you look at the
pictures now a rainbow wristband the
entire season in every game and nobody
picked up on it nobody saw that and his
teammates embraced him when he went to
the st. Louis Rams he was drafted by the
Rams in the seventh round the teammates
embraced him some of the team leaders
took him under their wing and really
tried to talk to him about just being an
NFL player how to improve his game and
so the players really I think
demonstrated where supports are um you
know your teammates are going to accept
you the the the interesting part about
Michaels story on the flip side of that
is to me there was no question that him
coming out hurt him in the draft and
there is no question to me that it hurt
him getting a job after after he was cut
from the Rams and then after he was cut
from the Cowboys I mean the that not a
single team called his agents to inquire
about him after he was caught by the
Cowboys after week six or whatever it
was that season that really tells you
that that NFL front office is the the
rich white guys in suits still have an
issue with this and and it demonstrates
a real
of leadership on this issue in in the
NFL particularly at the team level the
league I think would would love to have
an openly gay player in the NFL the
teams some of them are ready and some of
them aren't so Michael's story is a real
mixed bag of where professional sports
are what's he doing today uh you know
he's not playing football and and that's
the most disappointing part to Michael
you know Derrick Gordon was a college
basketball player who came out of the
closet and he ended up not making it
into the NBA these guys they they their
identity is wrapped around the sport
that they they've played they made a
name for themselves on national
television and I know to Michael that
he's not playing the NFL wolf and that
that I don't believe he really did get a
fair shake in the NFL I truly believe
that I think that's gonna haunt him and
I think it will haunt a lot of people in
the NFL for a long time cyd Zigler
Michael Irvin plays a large role in your
book fair play yeah why look Michael you
know when I first met Michael Irvin he's
NFL Hall of Famer played for Miami
Hurricanes in college played for the
Dallas Cowboys in the NFL when I first
met Michael you know Michael is this
ladies man he is a man's man he is he's
the man right I mean he is you do not
get any greater of a of a persona than
Michael Irvin has he is a a masculine
man and as I got to know Michael we just
had a mutual acquaintance and I started
doing his radio show Michael opened up
to me he had a gay brother
and despite you know being raised in the
best Southern Baptist household and
being deeply Christian he was done did
not oppose same-sex marriage and this is
in 2011 and and Michael agreed to do a
cover story for out magazine which is a
gay men's magazine in the United States
agree to do a cover story for which he
he decided to appear
less on the cover of a gay men's
magazine see how this this man's man
appearing that it was just it was just
an incredible it was a perfect storm and
and and what was amazing about Michael
is it was so calculated by him he wanted
to jump start a conversation in the NFL
about about gay people and gay issues
and he did because the warrants apps and
the Kurt Warner's of the world they all
took notice when when Michael Irvin
decided to be shirtless on the cover of
a gay men's magazine talk about his gay
brother and talk about same-sex marriage
in 2011 and I rely look at that point as
a really important point a turning point
in our movement and the LGBT sports
movement one of your chapters is on
religion and sports why well
religion has a real strong grip on
sports in the United States and it dates
back to the early 20th century it was it
was very intentional by the church to to
embrace sports and and you know team
prayers in the role of religion team
chaplains it's it's a very very powerful
part of American sports high school
level at the college level and in in in
the professional ranks and and
unfortunately a lot of churches have a
problem with gay people and so when you
have you know this constant
reinforcement of Christian doctrine part
of that doctrine for a lot of people is
very painful for a lot of gay people is
very painful so I think it's important
to talk about gay people in religion
inside of sports just because of the
stranglehold that that that that
religion has on sports in so many
corners of sports
if the flip side is that to a lot of
people
sports is religion right it is it is the
most important thing in their life but
at the same time are are you still
seeing that today where Christian
churches are sure loyal emphasizing I'll
tell you one of the things that I've
been fighting about is the NCAA the NCAA
allows member institutions that have
specific anti-lgbt policies for example
BYU bring them young University is
operated by the Mormon Church they have
in their student handbook specific
policies that forbid homosexuality and
even even even to gay people dating one
another it forbids it and that the NCAA
claims to be this incredible inclusive
organization but allows its member
institutions just because they're
religious to actively discriminate
against LGBT student athletes to fire
coaches simply because they're gay we
know that some of the institutions have
done this that the NCAA allows that is
odd to me it's very damaging to the LGBT
people and in collegiate sports and and
yeah this this is really happening today
so do you would you advocate that a BYU
should not be allowed into the NCAA the
NCAA says that inclusion includes LGBT
people they pulled some
championship-level events out of North
Carolina because of the H hb2 law that
targeted our community they cannot say
that they are an inclusive organization
and at the same time allow BYU and it's
anti LGBT pop LGBT policies that really
harm LGBT students so I'm not going to
tell the NCAA what to do but they can't
do both what's a reaction in the big
five to you as a reporter and somebody
who runs out sports I have a fantastic
relationship with people in the front
offices of every single leak I think
about Greg Aiello with the NFL who's you
know their head spokesman and and and
others in the NFL and and I mean they
answer my phone calls they answer my
questions sometimes it's on the record
sometimes it's on background
Billy Beane and Major League Baseball is
incredibly communicative he's a vice
president with the league so I have I
have a great relationship
you know I think because I have and Jim
Basinski my business partner in out
sports we've demonstrated fairness that
we're going to treat you fairly we're
going we are going to say when we think
you misstep and when we think we think
you got it wrong and when we think you
got it right we're gonna say that too
and and I hear from people that they
respect that we're we're honest and
we're fair and you talk in fair play
about some of the interviews you've done
with players are the players open to
talking with you as well
yeah I talk in the book about going to
an NFL PA the NFL Players Association
event and a representative of the NFL PA
having a big problem with me asking gay
questions of some of their new players
and this is back three four years ago
I've never been a couple who did not
want to talk to me for sure but you know
Kurt Warner is is a devout a devout
Christian God is the most important
thing in his life and he and his wife
stopped and chatted with me for a few
minutes about these issues very openly
so I think most of the athletes get it
that it's about your teammates and about
about sports and about winning together
and not about who you sleep with cyd
Zigler
is the author of this book Fair Play how
LGBT athletes are claiming their
rightful place in sports
thanks for being on book TV thank you
and our coverage of the Miami Book
Festival continues now up next to
medical writers Peter Kramer and Luke
Dietrich talking about their books
ordinarily well and patient h-m this is
live coverage of Miami
[Music]
[Music]
hello I'm Lila kite and I am a friend of
the book fair and also the chair of the
Brickell Avenue literary society I
forgot with the last session to tell you
to turn your cellphone's off most of you
are old hands and you probably had them
off all day but please do I want to
thank you for coming and supporting the
Book Fair and there are other people
that of course we need to thank I'd like
to recognize our sponsors who make all
of this possible the knight foundation
OHL Arellano can construction the
Batchelor foundation and the de groot
foundation otherwise i want to
especially thank the friends of the book
fair for being friends and those of you
who aren't friends please do join us
become a friend because they're
wonderful things going on all year long
I'd like to especially thank miami-dade
College for sponsoring this important
event you know it's the biggest and the
best in the country and we're very
grateful to them for that I'd like to
introduce Clyde
de Groot you've heard her thanked her
foundation thanked over and over in
these programs play bet and her husband
Charles de Groot our longtime and avid
supporters of the book fair they chaired
the de Groot Foundation which focuses on
innovation education and culture it has
a particular interest in the visual and
literary arts they partnered with the
book fair to create a prize the Miami
Book Fair de Groot prize to be awarded
to an author with an unpublished novella
so please give a very grateful welcome
to Clyde at de Groot who will introduce
the authors to this season
[Music]
good morning and welcome to the science
of the mind it is my pleasure today to
introduce our two authors Luke Dietrich
and Peter Kramer I will introduce one
and he will come out and then the other
so I'll begin with Luke Dietrich who is
a national magazine award-winning
journalist and a contributing writer at
the New York Times magazine in his new
book patient hm a story of memory
madness and family secrets dietrich
explores the limits of science and the
limits of the mind in his fascinating
and sometimes troubling true story of
patient H M and M miss Nashik who became
the most studied human research subject
ever Luke introduces us to a man who
forever altered our understanding of how
memory works and whose treatment raises
deeply unsettling questions about the
human cost of scientific progress as one
review said patient HM combines the best
of biography memoir and science
journalism to create a haunting
endlessly intriguing story one that
reveals the wonders and devastating
things that can happen when hubris
ambition and human imperfection collide
please welcome Luke Dietrich
[Applause]
Peter Kramer is a psychiatrist a writer
and Brown University Medical School
professor with his landmark book
listening to Prozac
dr. Kramer became one of the most well
known psychiatrists in America
he has written a number of other books
including against depression and should
you leave his articles and book reviews
have appeared in the New York Times The
Washington Post and slate ordinarily
well the case for antidepressants
reengage --is us with an important
debate that has brewing been brewing
since the dawn of biological psychology
do antidepressants work and reminds us
that each patient is a person Peter
Kramer writes with empathy about his
clinical encounters over decades as he
weighed treatments analyzed the results
of clinical trials and observed the
influence of medications on his
patient's life and on their symptoms
crucially he shows how antidepressants
act in practice less often as miracle
cures than is useful and welcomed tools
for helping troubled people achieve an
underrated goal becoming ordinarily well
please welcome Peter Kramer
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning I hope you're having a good
time what I you know this is I'm a
repeat customer a repeat offender at the
Book Fair and I forget between visits
how wonderful it is just exciting to be
in my office
I want to speak to you a little about
this book ordinarily well and say how it
came to be written this is my seventh
book and it is more of a message or
campaign book than most so I really want
to talk to you about just how we know
that I need to put a little bit about
antidepressants whether they work and
how important is to know the answer to
that question it's a book I'm glad to go
around the country and speak about
because beyond wanting to people to read
the book I want them to understand
something about this important
technology treating one of the serious
chronic illnesses of humankind when
doctors begin a talk they always have a
conflict of interest slide and I was
named by the British Medical Journal a
few years ago as one of a handful of
psychiatrists who speak a fair amount in
public who have not taken money from
drug companies or insurance companies
and so on and that
[Applause]
list is being revised this year and I'm
still on it I this is as I say my
seventh book and I think people are so
mistrustful of anyone saying anything
positive about medical approaches to
mental illness and whether they've had
drug company influence and so on you
just want to indicate that I have worked
hard to characterize how we deal with
mental ailments all together so I've
written about in listening to prozac a
response to intimations that there's a
real biological sides temperament and
personality about theories of intimacy
about cultural views of melancholy and
whether we romanticize it and about the
history of psychiatry and the grounding
for some of our non biological
treatments among other things I came to
this book because of a intensely
personal story I have a friend who I
call Alan in the book real person when
they sort of signal article four
beginning this discussion appeared in
the sunday review in The New York Times
The Times went and called Alan to make
sure they existed in that what I said
about him was right he had had a very
serious stroke he's someone I've known
since college days and it's a kind of
stroke for which antidepressants are
very useful treatment not for the
reasons if we're going to talk about
that is not only because they prevent
depression in people have recently had
strokes and seem to be quite safe in
them but also because with this
particular kind of strokes they help
people regain muscle movement and his
neurologist had not given
antidepressants and I asked why and with
the help of a relative of Alan's who's a
doctor my own influence he was given
that option and went on antidepressants
and did a little bit better and I took
the opportunity then to ask some
researchers in this field of the overlap
between depression and
stroke what their experience was and
they said yes because they've been a lot
of articles both professional and
popular critiquing antidepressants that
neurologists have become less willing to
use antidepressants and I thought about
my own patients and there's one other
story I tell in the book whom I called
Nora but really an amalgam of patients
who would do very well on
antidepressants these are people with
serious mental disorders who maybe their
marriage their jobs their functioning
all together ability to go out and work
were helped corrected by her to
depressants and they would come in and
said read that these medicines are just
placebos maybe I should go off and I'm
always happy to discuss patients going
off antidepressants but for reasons
related to the course of their illness
and you know how well they're doing and
so on and not because they don't work at
all and I occurred to me that my
practice wasn't that difficult it wasn't
that different in its implications that
kind of question wasn't that different
from the neurologist questions about
Alan that I to have patients whose
brains are being gravely afflicted by an
illness and for which their biological
treatments and we're having doubts about
this one question their efficacy we
could a lot of a lot of have a lot of
questions about side effects and when to
come often and when they're overused and
so on but this one question about
efficacy I thought needed to be answered
that in the same way that that
neurologists need an answer Nora needed
an answer and I thought that I might be
a person to try to give that answer I
was implicated because in the senior
Prozac I'd raised lots of worries about
antidepressants whether they might be
overused to tweak people's personality
and so on and I thought it might be
incumbent on me to make clear that the
main central use of antidepressants that
is treating this major disorder
depression and we're talking about this
chronic recurrent
often worsening with time disorder that
involves things like low mood low energy
suicidality difficulty with
concentration and memory and so on that
that core uses the medication was not in
question now why is it in question at
all you may have read headlines like
these this was in USA Today this was
Newsweek why antidepressants know better
than placebo these are like dummy pills
that don't have any inherent efficacy
and an oppression president lifts all in
your head is USA Today this is the New
York Times is more sober version of that
same headline this is on 60 minutes
you're saying if you took a they took a
sugar pill that would have the same
effect and this is the New York Review
of Books Marcia Angell broadening the
skepticism to all psychoactive drugs so
not just antidepressants but some of the
others a psychiatrist use and I since
this is a very short talk I thought I'd
just give you my conclusion or what I
think the sign says which is that these
drugs work about as well as other drugs
that doctors are content to use drugs
for asthma and allergies and so on and
in your own experience if you've taken
excedrin for headache the odds that your
headache will get better about as well
as the odds is someone honor and a
depressant will do well down the road
relative to the efficacy of placebo that
is the inherent advocacy is about the
same as those of drugs we use that a lot
of the controversy has to do with
reliance on averages the way
antidepressants work is some people
don't do well on them at all they even
have side effects than they report doing
worse and the vast majority do better
and about half of that vast majority do
very substantially better so their
episode of depression may be ended or
they'll just function a great deal
better and so if we look at categories
like recovery or
remission and so on that rather than
looking at averages if we look at people
antidepressants do especially well and
they do even better if we look at
quality of life so if we say the kinds
of objectives I've talked about if we
ask are people enjoying their lives are
they back at work are their parenting
their children that on those measures
anti depressions presents outperform
placebo quite remarkably they work for
all levels of severity despite what some
of those headlines said they work up and
down the line
so for milder major depression
depression with fewer symptoms and
milder symptoms they work as well as
they work for severe depression and they
are especially good with chronic
patients not because acutely ill
patients don't respond well but because
chronic depression responds so poorly to
placebo that the extent of the over
performance is more obvious with chronic
depression they work on the spectrum of
problems that I wrote about in listening
a prozac that is they make people more
assertive and more confident sometimes
more often that I thought at the time I
was writing listening your Prozac more
reliably in general personality traits
that are altered by depression tend to
resolve in the direction of more
adaptive personality traits and they are
especially good if people respond to any
depressants and they're kept on them for
a while if you look two weeks four weeks
a halfie or a year a couple of years
down the road it's always the case that
people who stay on medication do better
than people come who come off medication
and that is even taking into account
things like the the difficult period
people sometimes have often in the
immediate wake of coming off medication
and that's not to say that people should
be kept on medication indefinitely but
just that their odds of relapsing or
having another episode and so on
our decreased by staying on medication
they've had a very long recurrent
worsening course of illness often listed
on medicine quite a while and in
addition if you look at disorders like
stroke and heart disease and so on where
there are very great risks of becoming
depressed and again this is not
something people have to do but just
part of our awareness of how these
medications work if you give them
antidepressants proactively an
excitation of the possibility of their
becoming depressed acutely they are much
less likely to become depressed than if
they're given no treatment or placebo so
these are highly effective medications
and a lot of what the book is about is
about our cultural interest in having
these medicines not work why we are
willing to believe what I think is
fairly second or third rate research
that is the basis for these news
articles that says if they resemble
placebo or don't work I'm gonna stop
this just to give you a little taste of
the the voice of the book and give you
another motivation for my having written
this book I entered medicine in the
1970s at Harvard where antidepressants
were very rarely given and I saw very
severe cases of depression of us what we
see more rarely now and they were
treated with psychotherapy it was
considered a failure of imagination to
use medication and we saw a very deep
levels of depression on sort of what was
already a quasi until ideological basis
the medicines had been available for 20
years and were their efficacy was well
documented so I want to read you a
little bit about a patient and this is
an old postcard of the year the student
cannot just the way I wanted but anyway
of the hospital where he was treated so
here's here a few minutes of the book
when I say in a lecturer conversation
that nearly two decades after the
discovery of the first antidepressants
it was not unusual
to meet hospitalized profoundly
depressed patients who had never been
offered medication listeners object that
I must be mistaken
but the adoption of antidepressants was
far from uniform if evidence is needed
and abounds in the documents surrounding
a famous legal confrontation oh sure off
the chestnut lodge of issue was a
treatment that took place in 1979
rayful osha Roth was a kidney specialist
in an entrepreneur the own dialysis
centers who suffered from anxiety and
depression shortly before he turned 40
OSHA Roth became depressed and was
treated with psychotherapy and
antidepressants he improved but only
moderately so he lowered his own
medication dose deteriorated and signed
into chestnut lodge a psychiatric
hospital in Rockville Maryland the lodge
had hosted leading mid-century American
cycle analysts such as Frieda from
Reichman and Harry stack Sullivan and
OSHA roughs treatment proceeded along
analytic lines he slipped further losing
40 pounds or more and becoming so
agitated he paced constantly that his
feet needed medical attention
despite questioning by a consultant
hired by the family OSHA Roth's doctors
continued to withhold meditation in 2012
Rayo Shroff sent me a transcript of a
treatment planning meeting from early in
his stay
it shows the ward staff discussing
suicide risk a psychiatric aide said we
are very concerned about him because
when he looks like he's depressed he
probably is really depressed and the
nursing staff feels like we have to
watch him closely
in contrast the ward administrator put
across problems in Psychological terms
he asked to be put on medications I told
him that it would interfere with what he
came here for I titled this chapter what
he came here for I told him that he
needed every neuron to observe what
absorb what we're telling him here and
that medication would interfere with
that I told him that if his pacing got
out of hand
we'd have to wrap him in a cold wet
sheet pack the social worker told us of
patients were wrapped in wet sheets to
calm them down the social worker told us
that his agitated
was reminiscent of the obnoxious conduct
that his father had indulged in oh sure
off explained that he had a contract
worth hundreds of thousands of dollars
annually this is in the 70s that could
be voided if he did not return to the
office within six months a doctor at the
lodge scoffed at the deadline this is
from the transcript again this business
that he created was a giant breast that
was going to restore the scenes of
adoration that he had with his mother
the staff anticipated a hospital stay of
at least three years to rework or shrubs
personality Oh show off lost control of
his business his marriage ended after
seven months a friend had OSHA removed
to another hospital silver Hill in
Connecticut where he received
antidepressant antipsychotic medicines
improved within three weeks was
discharged in three months and returned
to medical practice Oh show-off sued
chestnut lodged for negligence saying
that medication would have spared him
lost income and the book here I
discussed a little bit to leave the case
and the back and forth it was not one of
these dispositive precedent-setting
cases because in the end it was settled
out of court but but in Olaf's favor and
that made hospital administrators demand
of their staffs that where medication
was potentially useful they consider it
and that created a lot of resistance
among psychoanalytically oriented a
hospital based physicians so it created
a conflict in the field that I think
energized a lot of the resistance to
medication that also made them more
widely used
Jerald Clare man who's another figure in
the book because he became a mentor of
mine in the Carter Administration who
had served as an expert witness for OSHA
Roth followed up with him writing in
1990 Clare Minh reported the ten years
out supported by psychotherapy and
medication Oh sheriff had experienced no
downturn serious enough to interfere
with his work or social functioning I
contacted ray ashram as I said in 2012
when he was 73 he was living in New
Jersey with a long-term girlfriend
practicing medicine he said that he'd
gone through bad times but never again
experienced anything like that
devastating episode
an experience for which as he put it
depression was a whimp of a word he
added that his career had never fully
recovered and that he'd experienced
extensive harm in his private life as
well I don't doubt that OSHA Roth had a
strong personality part of the claim was
that you know they were treating
personality not depression on the phone
he sounded irascible like the kind of
person who makes history and their
discussion the chest net large staff and
recognized that the traits they hope to
moderate were ones that had led to their
patients professional success Oh sh ruff
had a wide range of reference a sense of
humor a quick mind in a sharp memory he
could be poignant Oh Sheriff described
the course of his depression back in the
seventies it began with crying spells
and panic attacks that he entered a deep
dark tunnel he was beyond sad what was
worst was the absence of feeling
medication restored and he could cry
again you're glad to feel sad you
appreciate Birds blue skies the smell of
grass antidepressants had sustained him
for the rest of his life of his time at
chestnut lodge Oh sheriff said you were
not treated you were tortured the
literature of tortures most relevant
three weeks after our conversation one
week after his final email to me ray
Ostroff died in his sleep so you know
that to me is part of what's at issue
here you know are we going to be
hubristic as is in this case that Luke
will talk about about one of our
treatments at the expense of others oh
we're really trying to think about what
people need the book as I write it has
two strands one is whether
antidepressants work and how we know and
this is complicated I always get asked
by journalists do you rely just on your
clinical experience you rely just on
this to that kind of study and the
reason I wrote a book is that there are
so many reasons that we have confidence
in these medicines and they all point in
the same direction and about to the same
degree so you know when you read the
book you're given
an introduction to some of the methods
Helly diagnose how we measure what
constitutes an adequate level of
response how we combine studies and so
on and also what some of the downsides
are of those statistical methods and
what can go wrong as well as hearing
stories and hearing about the history in
this way and my notion is to think as I
do as a clinician that when a doctor
sits down with a patient what do we want
that doctor to know what do we you know
if there becomes a moment a moment
arrives a moment where someone has to
decide should we recommend medicine or
not
what should inform that choice the
serious question I think and on the
other side is this claim that
antidepressants don't have inherent
advocacy that we were through placebo
effects and I'm gonna talk a little
about that strand of the book that is
the critique of antidepressants it
begins very early so antidepressants the
notion that there's an antidepressant
starts entering the literature in the
late 1950s by 1960 or 61
they're already articles saying that
these medicines are just placebos even
though they are among the best tested
new medicines in medicine this whole
idea of the kinds of studies we rely on
now randomized controlled double-blind
trials that had was just coming into use
as these medicines were
contemporaneously everybody understood
these trials would have to be used so
this started developing a literature
showing just what the extent of efficacy
these medicines were this is Robert
Lieberman a very distinguished
psychiatrist when he was a medical
student a student at Dartmouth in the
late 1950s into the 60s he wrote an
article that said among other things
that antidepressants were like placebos
was a second-year medical student and
there you know really was not evidence
for this it was it was there was so much
wish on the part of the
psychotherapeutic Lea oriented part of
the profession that this article was
printed in a major psychiatric journal
Lieberman perhaps on the strength of
this was able to transfer to Johns
Hopkins the work was very strenuous he
became depressed did well on
antidepressants and I tell the story at
some length in the book but it goes on
for quite a while with him and his
physicians resisting antidepressant
treatments periodically he becomes so
ill they needs electroconvulsive therapy
shock therapy is maintained on
antidepressants and became one of the
first doctors Oh